Some APIs will also require
you to set up credentials and
access using
the Google Developers Console.
For example,
in the maps course, you'll need to
enable your map to use the maps API.
And if you look here on the left,
there's APIs & auth.
When I select that,
and I select APIs, and
then I select enabled APIs,
you can see the APIs that I've enabled.
And one of the map apps that I build,
I'm using here
the Google Maps Android API version 2.
You'll also need credentials for
some of your apps.
So for sign in maps, and some of the
others, the system needs to know which
apps are using which resources, and as
a result credentials need to be enabled.
And here you can see I've
selected credentials.
generated an API key for
the apps that I've built
that are using Maps.
As you need them, you'll be stepped
through everything that you need to
do on the Google Developer's Console
in the lessons, but
it's good to have a look at it.
Go to console.developers.google.com and
have a play around.